I have a question about Daredevil is
everything that happened on the Netflix
series a part of the Sacred timeline or
is it not so I can say that we've been
we've been up until this point we've
been a little bit Cy about what's sacred
timeline what's not sacred
timeline so Marvel Studios has actually
went out publicly and confirmed
something pretty crazy and the reason
they are doing this is because Marvel
Studios is essentially starting kind of
a new corner of the MCU they are
bringing out a new style of content that
is going to exist on Disney plus that is
both connected to the MCU is MCU Canon
but also exists in its own realm and
that is the Marvel Spotlight Banner now
many of you have probably heard that
characters like The Punisher are
returning we're going to see John
Bernthal return as Frank Castle AKA The
Punisher in the Daredevil series
Daredevil born again and one of the
biggest questions that Marvel f fand
have had really since the MCU and the
Netflix Marvel series have existed at
the same time and especially now since
we are getting the same actors playing
the same characters from the Netflix
series now entering the MCU the biggest
question is are these characters the
same did the Netflix series shows the
Marvel shows on Netflix take place in
the MCU are they Canon are they
connected or not because it does get
kind of confusing when you see that
Charlie Cox is is now in the MCU playing
Matt Murdoch AKA Daredevil and Vinnie
denafo is also in the MCU now playing
the same character he played in the
Netflix series Daredevil playing Kingpin
once again well good news for Marvel
fans because a Marvel Studios executive
in fact pretty much the most important
person at Marvel Studios who could
confirm this really did confirm it with
the exception of Kevin fogy the
president of Marvel Studios but
essentially we have an official
confirmation from Brad wib m in a recent
interview for the upcoming show echko
where he was recently asked specifically
about the Netflix series and if they are
a part of the Sacred timeline or not in
which he did confirm they were and he
said that he himself could personally
confirm this we'll dive into this and
why it is such a huge deal in this video
but if you're new be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest MCU videos and if you subscribe
and leave a comment you are
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series
X some Marvel Legends items or DC items
the winner picks one item and we pick
one winner at the end of every single
month so again this confirmation is
coming from Brad wbam and he is the
right person to confirm this he is the
head of Marvel Studios TV animation and
streaming so basically he is the guy
behind Disney plus he's the main man
behind all of the content that gets
produced for Disney plus he is basically
the Kevin fige of the TV side of the MCU
right now now if there's anybody to
confirm this it is him and he does
confirm this in an interview with Screen
Rant when talking about Ekko in the
interview they talk about the Marvel
Spotlight Banner how that's going to be
kind of a different vessel for Marvel
Studios content and we'll talk about
that more in this video as well because
this really is going to be a different
way for Marvel Studios to produce
content that I believe is going to be
very very good but first of course let's
dive into Brad wbam confirming that the
Marvel Netflix series are Canon to the
sacred timeline of the MCU so as I
mentioned this is a Screen Rant
interview hosted by Joe deckel Meer
interviewing Brad wbam and there's a
scene in one of the episodes of Ekko
where Daredevil fights Ekko and this we
knew we knew Daredevil was going to be a
part of the Ekko Series in some way
shape or form more than just a tiny
little Cameo but we know that he is
going to go up against Ekko in the fight
scene is going to be incredible I've
personally seen it and it's pretty
awesome so he goes on to ask if
everything that happened on the Netflix
series is a part of the Sacred timeline
or is it not and here is exactly what
Brad said and we'll play a clip from the
interview as well but he started off by
stating so I can say that up until this
point we've been a little bit Cy about
what's sacred timeline and what's not
that was born frankly out of a period at
the studio where we were like we have to
stick the landing with the Avengers it
was another part of the company
developing the Netflix stuff we were
aware of what they were doing they were
aware of what we were doing but it was a
lot it was a lot to balance anyways but
now that some time has passed now that
we actually see how well integrated the
stories are I personally Brad wbam will
confidently say that they are part of
the Sacred timeline and I'll play that
clip of him saying that here um I think
that I personally Brad windbound would
be confident in saying it is part part
of the Sacred time so as you can see
here they officially confirm that at
least Daredevil is a part of the Sacred
timeline the mcu's sacred timeline I say
Daredevil because they specifically
asked about the Daredevil Netflix series
and he specifically responded about the
Daredevil Netflix series however we
could probably assume that most of the
Netflix Marvel series that were put out
are indeed a part of the MCU sacred
timeline the reason we could assume that
is because once again John Bernthal who
played The Punisher on the Netflix
series is going to be in the MCU he's
going to be in the Daredevil series as
the exact same character Frank Castle
AKA The Punisher interacting with a
character that he's interacted with
before so if this is the same Daredevil
from the Netflix series then this is the
same Punisher from The Punisher series
and the relationship that they had
before is going to be the same that they
had on Netflix and I think this is a
giant win for many many MCU fans who
watched The Punisher and Daredevil and
also not to mention we have heard that
Jessica Jones could be appearing in the
MCU as well apparently she was supposed
to appear in the Daredevil series but
unfortunately Kristen Ritter had some
scheduling conflicts and could not
appear but insiders say that she is
supposed to return or I should say debut
in the MCU now are all the characters
from Netflix going to be Canon we're
unsure about that Luke Cage ironfist
we're not 100% sure but at this point in
time Marvel Studios has confirmed
Daredevil Kingpin and we are assuming
the Punisher as well are Canon to the
MCU timeline which is awesome now what's
interesting is that Vinnie denafo did
recently confirm that Daredevil the
upcoming MCU show Daredevil will be
under the Marvel Spotlight Banner as
well Ekko is the first show to be under
this banner and it's the first MCU show
to be TV mature but basically what this
means is and Brad wbam said this in the
interview as well he said you don't need
to know what happened with Thanos to
watch the echo series and the same thing
is going to go for the Daredevil series
and this could be very refreshing to a
lot of people especially if you were not
a hardcore Marvel MCU fan who doesn't
want to watch every single project that
has come out to understand what is going
on this is a breath of fresh air however
at the same time these events these
shows that take place under the Marvel
Spotlight Banner are still can to the
MCU they are still happening inside the
MCU but they are kind of stories that
are taking place on the side that you
can enjoy on their own however at the
same time the characters and the stories
that take place during the shows that
are released under the spotlight Banner
are still going to bleed into the MCU in
a good way the stories might not
necessarily affect what is happening
overall in the MCU but the characters
that are introduced will appear in other
events at least some of the characters
for example we've already seen Ekko and
Daredevil in other projects Ekko of
course was in Hawkeye and Daredevil was
in She-Hulk now you don't need to know
what happened in Hawkeye to watch Ekko
they do a good job at basically
explaining and recapping and I'm
assuming you really don't need to know
what happened with Daredevil and
She-Hulk to understand what's going to
happen in Daredevil Born Again however
Kingpin who was also in Hawkeye is going
to be a big part of the street level
Avengers team moving forward and they
confirmed this in this interview Brad
wbom basically stated that Kingpin is
going on to be kind of a big bad of the
street level Avengers team so even
though Kingpin is is existing in these
stories that are kind of oneof under the
Marvel Spotlight Banner he is still
going to go on to play a huge part of
the MCU the same thing goes with
Daredevil we know he's going to be a
part of Spider-Man so basically you
don't really need to watch Daredevil
born again to know it's going to happen
in the next Spider-Man film if Daredevil
appears but at the same time you're
going to get a really killer show with
Daredevil born again at least we hope
fingers crossed and I think this is a
great sign overall from Marvel Studios
they are are realizing that there are
people out there who don't want to watch
so much content all the time Marvel
Studios and Disney have already admitted
they put out too much content it got
oversaturated and the quality they
admitted did drop and they are going to
scale back on the content that they are
producing and before they were doing
Special presentations but I personally
like the idea of Marvel Spotlight a
little bit better I've talked about this
before but I believe that these projects
are going to be right in The Sweet Spot
when it comes to introducing new
characters or telling oneoff stories
let's take Ghost Rider or Nova or the
Silver Surfer for example these
characters have amazing Stories and
perhaps a special presentation that's
about 45 minutes to an hour maybe an
hour and a half long might not do the
characters Justice however Marvel
Studios might not want them to have six
to nine episodes for Disney plus project
while doing a limited series under the
Marvel Spotlight Banner would be a great
way to introduce these characters
because that way you don't need to know
anything about about what has happened
with them or anybody they're associated
with beforehand but you know they'll go
on to become a bigger part of the MCU I
think this is a great step in the right
direction for Marvel Studios and I'm
really really excited now that they have
confirmed that at least Daredevil and
The Punisher those events that happened
in the Netflix series are Canon to the
MCU sacred timeline but let us know what
you think about this in the comments
down below are you excited about this do
not like it put all your feelings down
below and please don't forget to like
this video And subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all the latest MCU news
you can find us on Instagram and Twitter
as well and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
woof